well talking about what we eat the food
industry is constantly being challenged
and redefined by new trends and dining
in the 1970s we had fondue parties in
the 1980s we had wine coolers and more
recently we've seen kale pop up on menus
everywhere in 2019 the New York Times
Kim Severson predicts the most popular
food trends will include new forms of
hybrid lettuce cooking with marijuana
and cheese tea from Taiwan piqued your
interest well the papers National Food
correspondent is here to talk about what
we can expect to see this season Kim
Severson great to have you at the time
morning now I have to remind you I do
not personally think these may or may
not go I'm just these are what
everyone's saying you're just reporting
yes just just saying what they're saying
so we've had two outbreaks of E coli in
romaine lettuce and you called it the
great romaine scare of 2018 how is that
going to impact salads through this year
well it makes people first of all think
about lettuce like Oh Mike what's in my
bowl so you know it's kind of a mindless
thing we see lots of romaine on the
salad bars so now people are really
thinking about it so we had the health
scare so people are worried about
romaine that's got now a bad rap and
then you know some food writers in New
York magazine they called little gem
lettuce kind of last year so I don't
remember a little gem you'll see on a
lot of restaurant menus so that's been
considered passe so now everybody's what
is the new lettuce we have a lot of
people who are doing this is very
important what is it lettuce listen you
want to be on the edge of this there's a
lot of vertical and urban farms that are
growing hydroponic lettuces and so you
can chefs are customizing the exact kind
of lettuce blends they want there's
something called celtuce which is it's
actually a very popular in Chinese
cooking that's got a big stem in a
little bit bitter top but keep your eyes
out I don't think anybody's named the
new it lettuce this came about about
salad robots
oh yeah no salad Robo which is the thing
you think oh great we need a salad robot
but imagine if you're if you've ever
been in an airport at midnight or if
you've had to spend time in a hospital
and there's no fresh food around yeah so
this is a machine that has 10 15 tubes
chilled tubes that are restocked during
the day and you
press your order and an iPad a bowl
comes under the lettuce or the
vegetables whatever's in your salad
drops down with the dressing and you
have a freshly made salad which like I
say if you've ever been anywhere
midnight they don't and everything's
closed
it might work the moms are on here are
going this would be good for like
schools other types of vending machines
Millennials interested in non
Millennials what are they drinking
well the Millennials are not drinking as
much as as as you all might what okay
there's a it's the first group that is
18 to 34 year olds are really into less
alcohol lighter alcohol drinks no
alcohol drinks and so a lot of
bartenders are coming up with drinks
that instead of you know these people
[Laughter]
the idea of socializing and having
cocktails that are more kind of culinary
forward so vinegar shrubs herbs and
instead of maybe Jim you would have
Prosecco as the alcohol or no alcohol at
all and not you know we're not using the
phrase mocktail anymore which is very
belittling but and hopefully they will
not use Negroni or no hito anymore but
this idea that cocktails are as much
culinary as they are for the bus so
certainly the madmen Manhattan era seems
to be over well we've been teasing this
all morning I know you've been
salivating the tea with cream cheese
cheese used to you ready for cheese - I
don't know I you know it's this is
something that very popular in Taiwan
and certainly is there certain a lot of
people who really like it it's green or
black tea and then it has a little cap
of creamed it's basically cream cheese
and or condensed milk a foamy cheesy cap
that can either be salty or sweet and
you sip the tea or just work with me
here
that'll be open and you sip the tea up
through that cap of cream cheese
essentially so it could be I think that
you ride this yeah it's not bad I mean
listen a lot of people who didn't grow
up with bubble tea yeah
learn to like it it may be an acquired
taste there's certainly a lot of people
absolutely love it I think that cheese
cheese biggest problems it doesn't have
a good PR agent a new name like cheese
dude are you gonna you have to try it
well you've got me interested I have to
say I'll stick with the lemon woods okay
[Laughter]
yeah my lettuce robot Severson so crazy
how do you do you wanna thank you